Tiger king there is a feature film
adaptation in development and I got
exclusive Intel from the potential
leading lady Tara Reid
are you asking are you cool cats and
kittens
we're definitely toxic now so you know
let's see what happens but it's not an
official offer yeah why would you love
to play Carroll basket I mean that's the
kind of role for me Kevin that's amazing
to have that kind of range and terror as
I can oscar-winner to play her nemesis
who would you want to play Joe exotic
what about Matthew Akane right you know
he dedicates itself to every similar if
you can make it right
it could be great with it but that also
scares me if I do it you know I don't
really like fires that's a little scary
I love doing sharknado so they were fake
until then you can see Terra in her new
indie drama fifth borough this isn't
about you
this is about her Terra plays a mom with
a teenage daughter that struggles with a
heroin addiction while also battling
cancer I just know that means that II
love you so much it's cause it's really
gonna be a good movie I'm proud of it
do you have um those mama instincts a
for your your dog Bella my dog bad it
hold on this is basil and this is Bella
I'm obsessed with them they've more
clothes than me
[Music]